so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny I want villains to get punished
but do you want the villains to learn
before they have to pay the ultimate
price that's such a Christian question
you're optimizing for minimal impact and
I think that is really the core of the
modern environmental movement it's not
this just blanket Collective desire for
as much life as possible and we're
somehow getting in the way of that it's
specifically against us that when they
discovered the greenhouse effect they
said this is going to on its own make
the earth a much more Lush a much more
Lush place there that you know they
speculated like the fruits are going to
be bigger and everything is going to be
Lush because we're going to have more
farmland and more biological and it's
kind of obvious if you have a warmer
world with more CO2 it's a more Tropical
World with more life it's a more green
world in the Life sense of green and yet
the green movement hates it because we
caused it so they can see no good in
anything we caused even when it leads to
more biological productivity it's
fundamentally an anti-human movement not
a pro life of any kind movement
the ineluctable
conclusion that has to be drawn from
that proposition is that any human
activity whatsoever is to be regarded as
evil even if it increases total
biological flourishing in terms of like
let's say the net metric tonnage of of
biological life on the planet and so
that's also perverse because that is
definitely a game that none of us can
win if the a prior rule is no matter
what you do you're evil then the only
solution to that is well how about a
hell of a lot fewer of you
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone watching and listening on
YouTube or the associated podcast
platforms I have with me today
Alex Epstein I'm looking forward to this
discussion he's a philosopher and energy
expert who argues that human flourishing
should be the guiding principle and the
appropriate metric for our energy and
environmental policy and our
determination of its progress he's the
author of the new book fossil future
as well as the New York Times bestseller
the moral case for fossil fuels which
was published in 2014. he's also the
creator of energytalkingpoints.com
a source of powerful well-referenced
talking points on energy environmental
and climate issues
Epstein began his work in 2011 with the
founding of the center for industrial
progress a for-profit think tank
offering insights into the world of
fossil fuels
and fighting back against the mainstream
Narrative of so-called environmentalism
widely recognized as a master of
persuasion and debate on energy issues
Alex has spoken to dozens of Fortune 500
companies and at dozens of prominent
universities including Harvard Yale
Stanford and Duke his alma mater
he's also a highly sought after
consultant on messaging working with
dozens of major political offices on
pro-energy Pro Freedom messaging
we're here today
to talk about the moral necessity of an
energy-rich future one that both must
and should rely on the Abundant
provision of the petro-based fuels so
carelessly currently demonized so
welcome to all of you who are
watching or listening and welcome to
Alex
so maybe we could just start by
having you walk through the book one of
the things I found interesting to begin
with was your discussion of the
motivations let's say
of some of the more radical people that
are pushing
what is purported to be a
pro-environment stance people like Paul
Ehrlich who clearly have an agenda that
could be more accurately conceptualized
as anti-human certainly anti-industrial
rather than pro-environment and and uh I
think that's something that's worthwhile
alerting everyone too especially given
the current state of
energy price increase in Europe let's
say and the consequences that's going to
have for the poor around the world let's
start with that though you you wrote
this book in 2014. let's talk about why
you wrote it and and how you think your
prognostications have fared in what's
almost an intervening decade
well I think one thing that's relevant
I'm not sure if you know this but
there's a new book 2022 called fossil
future which is the successor or
replacement to the moral case for fossil
fuels
um so I talk a bunch in that about what
how the moral case for fossil fuels has
fared and I think in terms of a
predictive book it's not primarily a
predictive book but it has been
extremely accurate because if you look
at what people have said in the last
eight or so years the main narratives
have been we're not going to need fossil
fuels as much as we used to they're
going to be rapidly replaced by solar
and wind primarily and that climate
impact the climate impact of fossil
fuels is going to be increasingly
catastrophic so we're going to see more
and more suffering and death uh from
climate related disasters and in the
book I talk about that's not going to
happen because one fossil fuels will
remain uniquely cost effective
particularly in a world that needs far
more energy which is something that was
not stressed in the past and is not
stressed enough today people are
starting to realize most of the world
doesn't have enough energy so replacing
fossil fuels is almost impossible given
that you're not talking about just
replacing it for the people who use it
but for the people who need it so I've
been very Vindicated on the continuing
cost effectiveness of fossil fuels and
then on the climate disaster point we
have documented that climate-related
disaster deaths are down 98 percent in
the last 100 years and they've continued
to decline and the basic reason is
because whatever impact we have on
climate that is negative it is far
outweighed by our ability to master
climate to neutralize all sorts of
climate dangers and so we're much better
off overall climate wise than we were 50
years ago and certainly 100 years ago
so so with regards to let's start with
the second one there the climate
disaster so the biophilic types and so
those would be people like Ehrlich
they seem to make the case that metrics
that involve human flourishing or even
human death aren't relevant because the
primary issue is to restore the
biosphere to something approximating
what it hypothetically was before there
were human beings which is a rather
strange notion All Things Considered and
so they might object to the fact that
you're using the mere decrease in number
of deaths say associated with climate
trouble with weather events as a metric
because the metric should be something
like the purity of the planet and so
what do you think about
what do you think about that argument
what metric should we be using to
determine whether or not a climate
emergency actually exists
well I definitely think we should be
using a human flourishing metric but in
a broad sense so the climate disaster
deaths are not the only aspect of that
but they're a very important aspect we
can also see that damages are flat or
down we can see that life overall is
much better and actually our ability to
preserve the most valuable parts of
nature is better generally when you're
not dependent on the land and dependent
on wood depending on your local
environment for your fuel and you're
wealthy you can be much better at
preserving the parts of nature that you
want to preserve if you look at places
in Africa and Asia and even now Europe
because they're now energy poor like
cutting down their forests it's because
they don't have better sources of fuel
so but I would I would challenge the
idea that Ehrlich is really using this I
think you called it biophilic standard
because if you look at his public
rhetoric he's always appealing to a
human flourishing standard so how did
Ehrlich become famous he became famous
through the 1968 book the population
bomb where he's telling human beings not
hey the planet is going to become more
impacted and that's intrinsically bad
he's saying you're all going to starve
and his close colleague Sean holdren who
was Obama's Chief science advisor no he
predicted in the 80s that we'd have up
to a billion climate related disaster
deaths from famine by 2020 which has
come and gone and the world is better
fed than ever so what I find is that
people who I think it internally they
don't really care about human
flourishing and they're really
optimizing for eliminating our impact as
much as possible but they appeal to
human flourishing to win over converts
because if they really said the best
possible Earth is the one that would
exist had we never existed and our goal
is to eliminate as much human impact as
possible as an end in itself they would
not win many converts well the lack of a
red wave during the midterms lead to
more Reckless spending by a more
emboldened Administration higher taxes
deeper inflation if you're unsure how
the next two years will unfold talk to
Birch gold group about protecting your
savings with gold Birch gold makes it
easy to convert your IRA or 401K into an
IRA in Precious Metals so you can own
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account gold is the world's oldest most
proven form of currency when inflation
soars and all other assets go sideways
gold is still there this month you can
get a free gold back with every five
thousand dollar purchase when you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
precious metals Ira with Birch gold by
December 22nd just text Jordan to
989898 Birch gold will help you own gold
and silver in a tax sheltered account
text Jordan to 989898 to claim your free
info kit on gold then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists with
every purchase you make before December
22nd you you'll get a free gold back
this is a great stocking stuffer just in
time for Christmas text Jordan to 989898
and protect yourself with gold today
okay so the case that you're making in
some sense is that the argument on the
radical pro-environmental side actually
varies sometimes
so so to speak in secret or behind the
scenes sort of voce I suppose the
argument is made that the planet would
be better off it was returned to some
natural and unspoiled condition and but
then public facing the arguments are
essentially
predicated on the argument that if we
don't do something drastic about let's
say climate change we're going to cause
a radical radical increase in actual
human suffering okay so that all has to
be straightened out conceptually before
we as a species let's say can move
forward intelligently on this front I
think the most
powerful point you made however and I
think this is where the rubber really
hits the road in more modern times is
that
even if you use the metrics that are put
forward by those who let's say oppose
the continuing use of fossil fuel so
those would be metrics associated with
climate change remediation and
environmental Improvement the policies
that are designed to drive energy costs
upward do nothing at all that isn't
counterproductive by their own
measurements
so you pointed out for example and this
is something that people really need to
be alerted to is that
because the because Europe has taken
this absolutely foolish route to rely on
so on wind and solar which is
intermittent at best
um
one of the things that's happening
because of the pressure on liquid
natural gas supplies
primarily is that there's tremendous
amount of deforestation occurring in
Europe at the moment because people have
to turn to sources of energy that are
actually at hand so that they don't
freeze in the dark in the middle of the
winter and so the thing that I find so
appalling about what's happening on the
environmental front at the moment is
that even by the metrics of the people
who are pro-environmental these policies
that are driving energy costs upward are
utterly counterproductive and you know
human progress.org has a lovely graph
showing the relationship between
attention paid to True medium to
long-term environmental sustainability
and overall wealth and what you see is
that if you can get as you make people
wealthier so as you remove them from
absolute poverty their ability and
willingness to attend to longer-term
environmental issues starts to increase
rather than decreasing and so this has
struck me for it I've known this for at
least 10 years that the best pathway
forward to a truly sustainable Planet
even by the definitions of the
environmentalists themselves is to drive
energy costs downward to the point where
we can remediate absolute poverty so
that people aren't driven to use up
um damaging and polluting immediately
available bio resources instead of
turning to more efficient sources of
energy and you are certainly making that
case in that in the 2014 book which as
you pointed out you've updated so
so that's the critical issue right even
by the metrics of the environmentalists
themselves the policies that were
presently pursuing on the energy front
are not only counterproductive
environmentally but they're driving poor
people into abject poverty we're going
to see a lot of that in Europe I think
it
I think I think it depends so I think if
you if you take the quote
environmentalists as having a kind of
pro-human interest in nature and
pro-human interest in lack of pollution
this is true but my belief is that the
core of it is the belief that human
impact is inherently bad it's
intrinsically immoral and and also the
belief is it's inevitably
self-destructive so nature is viewed as
this God that if we offend it through
our impact is going to punish us and it
really has this character where it's
wrong and doing the wrong thing is going
to destroy us and if you really think
about it that way all their policies
make sense because their policies are
really aimed at making human life worse
and ultimately reducing the human
population so it is true you can say
well yeah aren't you cutting down more
trees aren't you doing this but they
would say well if you use let's say we
had sheep free nuclear energy which
they've actually commented on
hypothetically when they thought Fusion
was possible I talk about this in moral
case and in fossil future the leading
environmentalist said this would be the
worst thing ever a totally clean cheap
abundant source of energy would be the
worst thing ever because of what we
would do with it and one of the leaders
called it like giving an idiot child a
machine gun and what they recognized is
that energy is really our ability to do
work which means our ability to impact
the Earth and when we use a lot of
energy we impact the earth a lot now we
impact it in a way that's beneficial to
us including we preserve the most
valuable parts of Nature and we give
ourselves an ability to enjoy nature
nevertheless it is a very humanized
Earth and to the anti-human
environmental movement that is offensive
so that movement is not about a clean
environment for us or for us to be able
to contemplate polar bears or go on
safaris or any of this it's about a
dehumanized earth it's the believer
right we are uniquely bad and we need to
get eliminated right right well but the
problem with that argument even if you
attempt to give the devil his due let's
say is that it's predicated on the idea
that if we pursued policies to decrease
our overall energy use and if one of the
consequences of those policies was the
relatively radical depopulation of the
earth perhaps by radically lowering
birth rates that while that
transformation was occurring
depopulation and de-industrialization
things would remain stable enough so
that
in our new poverty and our hopelessness
with regards to the future we wouldn't
be devouring the planet while we were
dying and I think that's a Preposterous
claim I don't see any peaceful Way
Forward that's based on compulsion and
poverty to reduce the population of the
world that isn't going to be absolutely
destructive on the energy on the
environment on the environment front
and and that the idea that if we had
more energy we would actually be worse
for the planet flies in the face of what
we've been discussing already which is
the fact that if people can't turn to
cheap and efficient and relatively clean
sources of energy and perhaps liquid
natural gas and nuclear would be at the
top of that list then they're going to
absolutely 100 percent turn to much
dirtier Replacements and we've already
seen that happening and well everywhere
I mean China is building coal-fired
plants at a rate that's so rapid that
everything the West is doing on the
climate amelioration front is absolutely
irrelevant and what has the UK in the
last week has already pledged to double
its coal Imports and Germany has had to
turn to its coal-fired plants to provide
backup power because wind and solar has
proved not only hyper expensive but so
unreliable that
well that when there's no power so when
the sun isn't shining and the wind isn't
blowing you have to have backup and it's
been cold that's it's been brought in as
a as a as a stop Gap so I just can't see
any way even if you accept the arguments
that you just laid forward you know that
there should be fewer people and that
the right planet is one that's
characterized by minimal Human Action I
can't see any way forward to that on the
energy poverty front that's not going to
be positively counterproductive
I mean I I agree I agree I agree with
you in terms of how it plays out and I
think it's important in general this is
not a scientific movement and part of it
not being a scientific movement is it
doesn't really have a long-term strategy
for achieving its anti-human goals it's
much more it has a lot of ritual in it
there's a lot of just hostility toward
kind of hostility toward anything that
has impact and you just oppose that and
then you assume things are going to get
better and so people didn't think
through what's going to happen when you
make energy more expensive what's going
to happen to the forest they didn't
think that through at all or when you
oppose nuclear what are you going to use
in its stead or when you make energy
expensive what's going to happen in
terms of riots it's just it's not at all
thought through and I think this might
be a lesson for us to have when we
contemplate these so-called plans for
net zero this is a movement that's very
much it has this hostility toward human
impact it opposes it wherever it sees it
and it just it has a quality of nihilism
to it and it's not thinking through it's
not thinking through either a
dehumanized earth or a human friendly
Earth it's sort of going after anything
that has impact but but my argument is
we need to switch our hostility toward
impact this view that human impact is
bad needs to be challenged human impact
is good if it makes the earth a better
place for human flourish
the biggest banks and investment firms
in the world are putting up to half of
their total assets into new Investments
what do they know that we don't maybe
that the economy is about to get worse
the CEO of JPMorgan just warned that
stocks could slide another 20 percent
bigwigs are moving their money into
Alternatives like Fine Art because fine
art has outpaced even the S P 500 over
the last 26 years by 131 percent even in
2022 Masterworks produced results in
early November Masterworks had a
strategic exit for a 17.8 percent net
return to their investors their last
three exits have brought in 1721 and 33
net Returns the next six months could be
some of the most important of your
investing Life paintings are selling out
in minutes but you can get Priority
Access at masterworks.com with promo
code jvp that's promo code jbp at
masterworks.com
jbp or click the link in the description
see important disclosure closures at
masterworks.com CD
[Music]
so yeah well it's a strange it's just
very strange issue philosophically
because
one of the things I wonder about is why
this idea that human beings are in some
sense in their activity antagonistic to
the Earth it's a very peculiar
metaphysical
assumption especially for people who are
hypothetically biologically minded
because if we're living creatures which
we clearly are and if we if we've
evolved in the same manner that other
living creatures have evolved which
seems relatively indisputable then how
is it that our very existence is somehow
antithetical to the flourishing of the
biosphere given that we're clearly part
of the biosphere and you and you see
this sort of thing with this idiot
assumption for example that bears some
of the same Hallmarks of this kind of
quasi-philosophical thinking that before
the Europeans came to North America that
the nativists were living somehow in
harmony with nature and that the entire
biosphere was three of the scars of
human interaction and that's utterly
preposterous I mean the Native Americans
were incredibly sophisticated
agriculturalists and the Western Plains
Indians burned the Prairies with con in
constantly to ensure that there is a
plentiful supply of the Buffalo that
they depended on and so human beings
have been
affecting the structure of the biosphere
ever since we've been around and that's
for a very long period of time and the
idea that there was somehow some
pristine state of nature before we
emerged on the landscape and that
there's some moral imperative to return
to that
it strikes me it's so incoherent that
it's barely comprehensible and there is
something like a hatred for Humanity as
far as I can tell that's lurking
underneath this hatred for Humanity
certainly a hatred for industrialization
and those actually turn out to be the
same thing I mean one of the things
that's really struck me as
incomprehensible
over the last few years is that
especially on the left is that you have
these joint claims being put forward
simultaneously on the left and one is
that we're radically pro-environmental
and we're also the uh philosophical
doctrine that is standing up for the
poor and oppressed and I think okay well
what happens when those two things are
pitted against each other and when are
they pitted well they're pitted when it
comes to discussions about cheap energy
because it's clearly the case and you
outline this in your book quite nicely
that the most effective way of
remediating absolute poverty so lifting
people out of the privation that's
associated at least with lack of
education but also with starvation
itself is to provide them with
cheap energy because as you pointed out
there's no difference between energy and
work and there's no difference between
work and productivity there's no
difference between productivity and the
eradication of poverty and so we are
pursuing these expensive energy policies
and hypothetically we're supposed to
benefit the planet although we're not
but we are definitely dooming people who
are already poor to a much more
truncated Horizon of opportunity and to
well to Absolute privation and
starvation in many cases yes I think
it's really I mean there are at least
two really interesting issues raised
here so this tension between the alleged
concern for poverty and then the quote
concern for the environment and then
this question of how this bizarre view
uh evolved you know because this was not
the view of our environment and our
impact 100 years ago and interestingly
it's not the view of our environment
that anyone who lives near Nature has
people who live in nature don't worship
nature as the superior God that can't be
impacted and I think it's my own
understanding of the history and I
really enjoy there's a book by um by Ein
Rand called the the new left the
anti-industrial Revolution and it was
written at the time that this was
happening and one of the analyzes is
basically there's a transition between
the old left and the new Left where the
old left claimed to be for industry for
productivity for prosperity and what
happened is that was clearly not
achieved by their pulse these communism
led to the devastation of Industry the
malfunction of Industry widespread
poverty and Rand said well you know the
left basically had a choice are you
going to stay with your anti-capitalism
or are you going to embrace capitalism
because you really care about industry
and productivity right right and
actually what they did was they they
kept their anti-capitalism and they
looked for new reasons to support
anti-capitalism and in the 60s they
decided on this issue of environment and
it was a convenient issue in a number of
ways one is the pro-capitalism side
didn't do a very good job with it
particularly rhetorically it didn't make
the point that well good environments
are made possible by Prosperity so the
idea of a good environment in a
humanistic way was co-opted by The
anti-capitalists Who had no right to it
whatsoever I mean look at the Soviet
Union and an environment but they they
owned that value issue but then they
packaged it with this hostility toward
human impact as such and what they
really did brilliantly was they took
over the schools so they put in the
schools this idea that human impact is
bad and especially the idea that it's
inevitably self-destructive because the
planet is this delicate nurturer that
our impact ruins and that has permeated
the whole educational system where
people think that we inherently are
destroyers of the planet and it has
permeated the scientific Community what
I call this delicate nurture or Dogma is
unfortunately pervasive in Earth
Sciences today it's a very primitive and
bizarre view it has nothing to do with
reality that our impact is inevitably
self-destructive actually our impact has
made the Earth much better overall
including safer from climate but
nevertheless I think it's really there
was initially a real political
motivation to spread this but now we
have this irrationalist philosophy that
has a mind of its own
yeah well that's okay so let's delve
into that a little bit because the other
thing that I've come to understand more
clearly in the last 15 years let's say
as the data has also become more clear
is that
so we lifted more people out of poverty
in absolute terms and also in relative
terms between 2000 and 2015 then we had
lifted people out of poverty in the sum
total of human endeavor before that and
it's quite clear that the reason for
that was that
fewer countries pursued absolutely
counterproductive economic policies of
the type that were put forward let's say
by the Communists when the Cold War was
raging and so you saw all over the world
including in places like
communist China that
there was a radical move towards
something approximating free market and
free trade between individuals and in
some countries that was implemented more
effectively than others but wherever it
was implemented at least
quasi-effectively people immediately
stopped starving
and so
and I'm I'm trying to make a case in
relationship to the anti-capitalism so
let's say that you are a genuine classic
leftist and you are actually concerned
with the poor especially remediation of
absolute poverty and you're looking at
the data and you see that after the
Soviet Union collapsed and there were
fewer countries turning to communist
Dogma to formulate their economic
policies and more countries started to
develop started to participate in the
broad free market that we drove poverty
down to its lowest level
um in absolute numbers or in in relative
numbers certainly than we'd ever seen
before in history and so then again
we're back to the same issue if the
spread of free market
uh policies
remediates absolute poverty which it
clearly does and in a staggeringly rapid
manner then what in the world is driving
the anti-capitalist ethos you know you
you said that there's this there's this
underlying metaphor of nature as
something like fragile virgin right
continually yeah what rendered
susceptible to our rat to our raping and
pillaging so there's a weird metaphor
lurking at the bottom of all that but
given the overwhelming data that
something approximating free market
freeze people from absolute poverty and
then conjoining that with the
observation that richer people actually
care more about the environment you're
left again with this question of what in
the world is motivating this there's
some deep hatred it's like a deep hatred
for Humanity itself but even at the
expense of the planet and so I still
struggle with trying to comprehend that
it's there's a kind of existential guilt
there for the for the crime of existence
itself it's something like that
I mean I think one there's one really
powerful uh fact about the increase in
prosperity that I draw attention to a
lot in fossil future because I think
it's very notable so I I point out I was
born in 1980 since 1980 we've had we've
gone from more than four in ten people
living on less than two dollars a day
and this is adjusted for inflation to
one intent so as you said this is the
greatest alleviation of poverty in human
history now what's really interesting is
if you survey and this was done in the
UK you might have seen this before but
if there's a survey of college-educated
adults in the UK about what has happened
to extreme poverty over the past 30 or
40 years and this is just you know an
objective documented thing there's no
question and so what happened is only 12
percent of people thought it got better
right 55 of people thought it got worse
and the rest thought it stayed the same
and it just shows you the level of
miseducation about this issue and I do
think a lot of it is the modern
anti-human environmental movement
because what they've done is they've
taught us that our impact ruins the
planet and so we just assumed that
because the world used a lot more fossil
fuels particularly China and India did
which drive with which drove much of the
increase in prosperity they just assume
that the world is worse and and what I
call I don't use this term in moral case
but I use it in fossil future our
knowledge system so the institutions we
rely on for expert knowledge and
guidance they've done a they've totally
failed at educating us about how much
the world has improved from a human
perspective and this goes back to my
argument that the anti-human
environmental movement they're trying to
pretend to be pro-human so they don't
want us to know that the Earth is a much
better place than ever to live they
don't want us to know that climate
disaster deaths are way down they don't
want us to know about the decline in
extreme poverty because it totally
challenges their narrative that impact
in general and fossil fuels in
particular are bad and if we recognized
how vital fossil fuels are then we would
be really afraid of these proposals to
get rid of fossil fuels in the next 27
years in a world that needs far more
energy and unfortunately we're starting
to realize this involuntarily because
these policies just implemented one
percent these anti-fossil fuel policies
just implemented a one percent success
rate in in the anti-fossil fuel
movements view have already led to a
global energy crisis
do you have a coffee lover on your
holiday shopping list Black Rifle has
all the best Brewing gear thermoses mugs
and apparel designed for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle sources
the most exotic roasts from around the
globe all coffee is roasted here in the
U.S by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts stuff your Christmas stockings
with the latest roast from America's
coffee for 10 off with the code Jordan
better yet sign your Secret Santa up for
a coffee Club subscription imagine the
joy of a pre-scheduled coffee delivery
your favorite roast when you need the
most it's the gift that keeps on giving
Black Rifle coffee company is veteran
founded and operated they take pride in
serving coffee and culture to people who
love America every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes go to
blackriflecoffee.com and use promo code
Jordan for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code Jordan
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
right right well you said
that the planet is getting better let's
say from a human perspective and so
we've looked at metrics like the radical
decrease in absolute privation but let
we can turn our attention momentarily to
the evidence that in many ways and
somewhat paradoxically and perversely
the planet actually seems to be doing
better from the natural perspective too
now you know I have been concerned about
I have believed for a long time that one
of our focal concerns might be
on the environmental front might
appropriately be something like
remediation of of misuse of oceanic
resources because I think we've done a
pretty cataclysmic job
of protecting our our especially our our
our Coastal our Coastal lands and the
and the Shelf environments just offshore
of the continents where pretty much all
the fish are I think we've done a
catastrophic job of managing that and
there are genuine environmental problems
um that I think sensible people should
take into account but you know I was
looking at a graph this week and I've
I've known about this phenomena for
quite a while phenomenon for quite a
while
that again in the last 15 years
a surface area
totaling 15 of the entire planet has
greened
I mean that is that's an area that's
larger than the continental United
States and it's so let's let's walk
through that for a minute so just so
everyone who's listening is clear in the
last 15 years
the planet has not got less green
it's got more green and not only a
little bit more green
stunningly more green 15 percent in
essentially in 15 years and that's an
area bigger than the continental United
States and that's happened pretty much
everywhere in the world and then you
might say well where is that happening
and perversely and contrary to all
predictions it's happening in the drier
areas of the planet especially in
semi-arid areas and here's the reason
um so
plants have to breathe and to breathe
they have to open pores on their surface
and the problem for plants when they
breathe with these pores is that they
also allow water to evaporate from their
internal structures and so the less
carbon dioxide in the air the more the
plants have to open their pores and that
means the more susceptible they are to
drying out and that means that they
struggle to exist in semi-arid areas now
what's happened as a consequence of
increased carbon dioxide production is
that plants can breathe easier and so
they don't have to open their pores to
the same degree and what's that what
that has meant is that the very desert
areas at least the semi-arid areas that
the climate apocalypse were claiming
would expand and spread so the
desertification of the world the exact
opposite has happened and the Sahara
Desert for example has shrunk to quite a
stunning degree and not only is the
planet 15 greener than it was in 2000
but but there are more trees in the
northern hemisphere than there were a
hundred years ago and as well as the
planet Greening
and and so you can think about that as a
victory
on the objective front for the natural
world at the same time the planet has
green because it's easier for plants to
survive our food crops have become much
more productive
for exactly the same reasons and so as
carbon dioxide output has increased the
planet has got not only has the planet
got Greener it's got greener in the
driest areas which is absolutely
stunning and remarkable and one of the
consequences of that increased screening
is that are agriculture production has
become not less efficient but much more
efficient and so I'm really wrestling
with how to conceptualize that
particular I just thought of an idea I
just thought of an idea I've never
thought of this before so we're just
trying it right now but I think I think
maybe we can think of three conceptions
of the earth which capture everything
we're talking about so my primary
conception is is evaluating the Earth
from the perspective of human
flourishing how how hospitable to human
beings is it and this includes like a
lush green beautiful world for us to
enjoy for many reasons you've talked
about but then the second one could be
looking at the Earth in terms of just
pure biological productivity so just not
even focusing on humans just how much
life is on the planet and this is this
captures what you just mentioned with
Rising CO2 levels making a Greener
Planet but then the third one and I
think this is really the core of the
modern environmental movement is a is an
unimpacted Planet so you're not
optimizing for biological productivity
you're optimizing for minimum symbol
impact and I think that is really the
core of the modern environmental
movement it's not this just blanket
Collective desire for as much life as
possible and we're somehow getting in
the way of that it's specifically
against us and I think you brought up
the perfect example which is the climate
catastrophe movements total non-interest
in kind of the obvious biological
productivity benefits of more CO2 and
this was not shocking or stunning this
is exactly what was predicted by the
people who discovered the greenhouse
effect when they discovered the
greenhouse effect they said this is
going to on its own make the earth a
much more Lush a much more Lush place
they you know they speculated like the
fruits are going to be bigger and
everything is going to be Lush because
we're going to have more farmland and
more biological and it's kind of obvious
if you have a warmer world with more CO2
it's a more Tropical World with more
life it's a more green world in the Life
sense of Korean and yet the green
movement hates it because we caused it
so they can see no good in anything
thing we caused even when it leads to
more biological productivity so I think
what you're bringing up really shows
it's fundamentally an anti-human
movement not a pro life of any kind
right right okay but let's let's talk
about that idea of impact it's like well
what is this hypothetical perfect world
that exists statically that would be
pristine and morally valuable in the
absence of human beings I mean the the
biosphere is a dynamic Place obviously
over any time scale and there's shift in
what constitutes quote the environment
there seems to be this presumption that
at some point in the past
when there was minimal human activity
the Earth was somehow optimized in the
biological but also the moral sense and
that any change in that whatsoever in
any direction hence climate change let's
say rather than global warming any
change in that whatsoever is to be
regarded axiomatically as evil but what
that essentially means as far as I can
tell the ineluctable
conclusion that has to be drawn from
that proposition is that any human
activity whatsoever is to be regarded as
evil
on on the face of it it doesn't matter
what it does
even if it increases bio even if it
increases total biological flourishing
in terms of like let's say the net
metric tonnage of of biological life on
the planet and so that's also perverse
because that is definitely a game that
none of us can win if the a prior rule
is no matter what you do you're evil
then the only solution to that is well
how about a hell of a lot fewer of you
but then you say well what's that
supposed to serve because if what we're
doing now is actually making the planet
more green and I'm saying that very
carefully because I know that that's not
a sufficient metric I am very concerned
with
issues let's say or conscious of issues
that are relevant like the potential
loss of a diver of biodiversity and also
the overfishing of the oceans let's say
so even although the planet is becoming
Greener that doesn't mean there that
there are no mistakes we're making on
the environmental front but those
mistakes have to be differentiated out
and they're all addressable and you know
as we get richer too and we can do more
with less and our agriculture becomes
more efficient if we can manage that
that also means even by the standards of
the environmentalists themselves that
we'll be able to set aside reasonably
large tracts of land and water to
maintain them in something approximating
a pristine and untouched State I mean
that's certainly something that should
be done on the uh on the oceanic
management front I mean the data that I
know suggests that if we
set aside a certain percentage of the
coastal area as Marine protected areas
and that might not be the most efficient
way to manage the oceans but it's not
bad that we'll reap the benefits of
having untouched nature so to speak
which is a an aesthetic and economic and
environmental good but will also
be able to replenish the oceans in a
manner that would be economically
productive and so well like why can't
why the hell can't we have our cake and
eat it too that is we can help people
become rich with the provision of of
plentiful energy and then we can put
aside tracks of the world so that
they're relatively untouched so that
biology can do its thing and like what
the hell is the problem with that
precisely well it's it's so I think
you're pointing to something really good
and something really bad something
really good is why my my new book is
called fossil future why Global human
flourishing requires more oil coal and
natural gas not less but part of it it
does talk about we can you know we can
increase all of these biological things
we can have a much more lush world we
can enjoy nature much more this is
fundamentally good news the more energy
we have the more control we have over
Earth and the more we can make
everything about it better for our
purposes including aesthetic things that
poor people can't possibly be confused
by but the bad thing here is it's a
really highlighting the nihilism of this
view that human impact is bad and again
I I really think it's the view is not
that we want a lush environment and
human beings are getting in the way of
that we want biological productivity and
human beings are getting away because as
you're pointing out they are opposing
all human impact including obvious
things that make the world better and so
it really is the view that if we did it
it's bad and you ask something like what
is it serving but it's a nihilistic view
so it's not really serving anything even
when you think when you think about
unimpacted nature it's not this
beautiful thing for us to enjoy it's
supposed to be protected from us so
that's really the view including our
enjoy with this evil of course orange
our enjoyment is of no consequence
whatsoever and and in fossil future and
in moral case I have a lot of quotes
from the leaders where they'll
occasionally let this slip out where one
guy for example who was reviewing Bill
mckibben's book the end of nature talks
about you know like a flourishing bios
sphere is more important me more
important to me than one human or a
billion of them yeah yeah let me read
that let me read that I've got it right
here so this is something that you cite
in your 2014 book I'm going to just read
it so everybody can hear it and I would
I would
ask everyone who's listening to really
think about this because this gets to
the strikes to the core of the issue as
far as I can tell so
for example this is from your book in a
Los Angeles Times review
of the end of nature
Kevin's influential book of 25 years ago
predicting catastrophic climate change
David M Graber research biologist for
the National Park Service wrote this
summary of mckibben's message
McKibben is a biocentrist
and so am I
we are not interested in the utility of
a particular species or a free-flowing
river or ecosystem
to mankind
they have intrinsic value more value to
me than another human being that's a
very interesting thing to say or a
billion of them which is also a very
interesting thing to say human happiness
and certainly human fecundity are not as
important as a wild and Healthy Planet
are no social scientists who remind me
that people are part of nature
but that isn't true
somewhere along the line at about a
billion years ago maybe half that we
quit the contract
and became a cancer
we had become a plague upon ourselves
and upon the Earth
it is cosmically unlikely that the
developed world will choose to end its
orgy of fossil fuel consumption
and the third world it's suicidal
consumption of landscape
until such time as Homo sapiens should
Desi decide to rejoin nature
some of us can only hope
for the right virus to come along you
know I cannot understand how anybody who
is
positively predisposed to Children let's
might we might say could read something
like that and not be absolutely shocked
to their core I mean so let's walk
through the claims the first claim is
a an untouched natural landscape of any
size
whatever untouched means is more
valuable in and of itself than any
individual human being or any group of
people no matter how large the number
okay so the implication there is
any number of human beings could be
sacrificed in order to preserve any
geographically demarcated natural zone
of any size so that's a yes a standard
of comparative value and then
the cancer metaphor well human beings
have deviated from the natural order
whatever that natural order is whatever
our deviation consists of and we've
deviated the same way a cancer deviate
so now the metaphor is human beings
equal cancer
and that's that's a hell of a metaphor
because
what we do with cancer is Strive to
eradicate it so these metaphors have
deep motivational significance so that's
a little bit on the appalling side let's
say and it's grounded in a very narrow
malthusian view of the world which is
that we're something like yeast
cancer let's say and left to our own
devices will multiply unchecked until we
devour everything and perish which is a
pretty dismal and only vaguely
biologically
um centered view of how human beings
conduct themselves because we're not
yeast in a bloody petri dish we're not
yeast and the world isn't a petri dish
let's put it that way and then you add
to that though the closing statement
which is something like those of us who
are properly oriented in our moral
Endeavor in relationship to the
non-human world can only sit and pray
that the right virus comes along so that
what so that we're we're radically
depopulated to to what to what degree
down to the half a billion people that
the world can hypothetically sustain
it's like every single bit of that to me
reeks of a
un underlying and barely veiled
brutal genocidal impulse
I I agree and what I want to draw
attention to is that this mentality
diluted or not to various degrees is
leading our thinking about what to do
about fossil fuels which is an
existential issue for the world because
the reason I go into this particularly
in fossil future is the point I'm making
is that the people and institutions were
trusting to evaluate what to do about
this source of energy that powers the
world that also emits CO2 and impacts
the climate those people are not making
that evaluation by anything resembling
the goal of advancing human flourishing
on Earth they are pursuing to a
significant degree this goal of
eliminating human impact on earth and
the economist George riesman had this
article a long time ago called the
toxicity of environmentalism and one
point he made that I never forgot is he
said listening to a modern
environmentalist is like listening to a
doctor who's on the side of the germs
somebody who doesn't have your best
interests at heart and as an example uh
one of the people I pick on very
deservedly in fossil future is Michael
Mann who's a climate scientist and
activist who is one of the leading
advisors and if you look at Michael Mann
statements one thing he has said is the
ideal population for Earth is a billion
people yeah yeah how can you possibly
say that there are eight billion people
like how can you possibly look at Earth
and say oh yeah it's too many people
that has a murderous impulse to it if
you just look at the Earth and you say
oh yeah seven billion people should go
and what I point out with Michael Mann
is that if you look at how he's
evaluating the issue he's totally
indifferent to the benefits of fossil
fuels he has a whole book people can
look it up called the madhouse effect
about fossil fuels and climate and he
doesn't mention any benefits of fossil
fuels for example he talks about
agriculture and fossil fuels he only
talks about negatives he doesn't once
mention diesel-powered uh agricultural
equipment or natural gas derived
fertilizer even though those make it
possible for us to feed need 8 billion
people so what we have is an anti-human
mentality
so so some of those who are listening
likely don't know that
the the very survival of about four
billion people so half the world's
population
depends in no small part on the
provision of ammonia as fertilizer and
ammonia is primarily derived from
natural gas and so what that means is
the not just on the energy front let's
point this out is that the the very food
that is provisioning half the world's
population is a direct consequence of
the cheap and easy accessibility of
natural gas and so
and so what what's the idea here that
we're supposed to reduce our provision
of fossil fuels and what are we going to
do on the ammonia on the ammonia front
we're going to drive the price of
fertilizer ever more Skyward well if we
do that because that would be the
consequence of reducing the plentiful
supply of natural gas if we do that then
what will happen is clearly food will
get more expensive and soil energy but
food will definitely get more expensive
and so what that will mean is that huge
swath of the world's population that's
living on the edge where they can just
right now afford enough food to feed
themselves so they don't suffer the
consequences of nutritional privation or
even die a huge proportion of those
people are going to be tipped back into
absolute poverty their children are
going to be intellectually stunted as a
consequence and they might well starve
and then you think well why would we do
that and if the answer is well you know
some of us really believe that the
planet should only have a billion people
on it if that if we have to have any
people at all then well maybe this is
all part of the unconscious drive
towards
and and conscious drive to some degree
reducing the planet's population no
matter what the price may be and then
you see how people justify this they say
things like well you know if we don't
take emergency action right now which
means let's make the poor even poorer
then the poor are really going to suffer
a hundred years from now and I think
look I don't have a lot of confidence in
your ability to predict even a decade
out much less a hundred years with your
unstable economic models that are
predicated on an equally unstable
climate model so we can forget about
your capacity to prognosticate 100 years
down the road but what you're saying
essentially is that the hypothetical
poor that occupy my utopian imagination
are much more important than the actual
poor right now who will definitely die
if we Implement our higher energy
price inducing hypothetical
environmental policies you know and one
of the things that strikes me is so
utterly absurdives partly why I found
your book so interesting is that somehow
the people who are making such arguments
have gained the moral upper hand even
though you don't have to scrape beneath
the surface very far to see not only the
genocidal metaphor and the genocidal
intent but the actual genocidal impact
of these policies because we're
definitely tipping people back into
absolute privation
we'll be right back to our conversation
with Alex Epstein in just a moment first
we wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new documentary logos and
literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johann
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away with
at least a sense of that
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
really interesting stuff going on I mean
I think one thing why do they have the
moral High ground and this is something
as is really a core mission of mine to
correct is that as I mentioned before
they really owned the issue of a good
environment starting in the 60s
including loving nature including caring
about clean air and clean water and more
recently caring about safety from
climate and that the pro-capitalism side
really didn't concern them to concern
themselves too much with this
rhetorically at least and so the
anti-capitalist side was able to own
this issue and when you own something as
important as our environment and our
planet you do get the moral High ground
and then they supplemented this with
this false alternative of you are either
a climate change believer who hates
fossil fuels or you're a climate change
denier who thinks fossil fuels are okay
so they created this total false
alternative which made no sense because
what makes sense with climate impact is
to weigh it along with the benefits of
fossil fuels you cannot judge a
prescription drug by only looking at not
negative side effects and you can't
judge fossil fuels by only looking at
negative side effects or exaggerating
negative side effects you have to look
carefully at our climate impacts
negative and positive and then weigh
them against the benefits that come with
fossil fuels including all the benefits
that protect us from climate so there's
this false alternative so what they did
is they owned the morality of caring
about our environment and they owned the
claim to science because the climate
change denial thing so-called didn't
make much sense because it's pretty
obvious we impact climate at least some
but so doing those two things they they
owned this issue so people think well if
I want to be a good person if I want a
good planet and I want to be pro-science
then I have to hate fossil fuels and a
lot of what I've tried to do and I think
Michael schellenberger and Bjorn
lombborg and Steve Cooney I think what
we've tried to do is look at climate in
a humanistic full context way and we're
breaking this false alternative which is
a lot of the reason we get a lot of
hostility so you said something there
that's very psychologically interesting
so you said said if I want to be a good
person
because the environmentalists have
captured this pro-planet narrative if I
want to be a good person then I have to
buy the human beings are bad for the
planet narrative but I'd like to take
that apart a little bit too
because it's not exactly true what you
said
the truth of the matter is something
like if I want to take a shortcut to a
good person
without having to being a good person
without having to put into the process
any real time and effort so that would
mean actually understanding the issues
that are associated with Environmental
Management and economic
sustainability which is unbelievably
complicated I mean Bjorn well in you too
schellenberger spent their whole lives
devoted to that endeavor trying to Wade
through the complexities it's actually
really difficult to
develop a sophisticated and genuinely
moral stance on the environment and the
economy it takes years and years of work
and it's also extremely difficult to be
a good person and merely feeling sorry
for the planet does not make you a good
person in fact what it makes you is a
shallow narcissist who's using the easy
identification with a genocidal ideology
to elevate yourself in the moral
hierarchy and we we see people who are
peddling this this Dreadful
story to young people and offering them
an easy shortcut to something
approximating easily trumpeted moral
virtue and that's the sort of moral
virtue that you can post on your
Facebook page when you claim that while
you're anti-capitalist and you're in
favor of the planet and therefore all of
a sudden you're actually a moral actor
and someone to be regarded with
admiration and none of that's true
because it's actually it's very
difficult to be a good person
but it's very powerful that I agree
entirely but it is very powerful and one
thing I talk about in fossil future and
this is a big mission of mine is the
moral Monopoly of what I call the moral
case for eliminating fossil fuels has to
be broken and yeah when you have what I
call a moral Monopoly you basically get
a halo over your head for saying I hate
fossil fuels I care about the climate I
care about the plant you don't need to
do anything you just need to express
this sentiment it doesn't matter if we
see you can fly on private jets you can
live any lifestyle you want as long as
you say this you get this Halo and the
other side gets devil horns on their
head but part of what's happened with
what I call the energy humanists
including me and Bjorn and Michael and
Steve is that we have now shown that
actually quote saving the planet in
their false view is hurting billions of
people and dooming them to poverty and
actually making our our environment
worse and hurting biology and so now
they hate that that's why there's such
vicious attacks because their racket is
coming to a close you you want it to be
a controversial the first thing before
winning a debate is actually creating a
debate there hasn't even been a debate
over the morality of fossil fuels Intel
fairly recently and once the debate is
created that that easy claim to Virtue
will disappear and those people will
just go pick the the next easy thing to
join yeah well you said that all you
have to do is Express the sentiment that
you care for the planet so that's
something approximating a feeling or a
subjective state of mind let's say yes
I'm a good person because I feel empathy
for the planet which is a pretty damn
low resolution definition of
implementable morality but you know it's
tied in with something else too so
imagine you're trying desperately to
make that case that the reason I'm good
is because I feel sorry for things
including the planet
well then you have to also
buttress that claim with the insistence
that sentiment subjective sentiment
itself is the only valid Arbiter of
reality and so that's something like I
feel therefore I am and I see that this
in this entire modern movement that
insists that identity is nothing other
than subjective feeling is actually
associated in a perverse manner with
this ability to justify a claim to moral
superiority by appeal to sentiment it's
like it's people see a picture of a like
a bedraggled kitten on on on the
internet and they go ah and they think
that because they have that reflexive
response which you know has a certain
moral virtue that all of a sudden
they're morally admirable people and
that's a lovely thing to believe and you
can extend that to something like well
I'm so concerned about the planet that I
can barely sleep at night it's like well
fair enough that might be an indicator
of your moral virtue although I suspect
not but the real question is do you
actually know anything about the problem
have you spent any work real work in
differentiating your knowledge of the
problem are you taking any concrete
steps whatsoever to solve it apart from
hand waving sentimentally and do you
have metrics in place that actually help
you measure whether or not what you're
doing has a beneficial impact and that's
also complex that if you bring two
people's attention the necessity of
thinking it through all they do is get
irritated at you like they get irritated
with Bloomberg's a classic example
because he's the person I think and I'd
like your opinion on this you know I
don't think there is anybody who's a
more effective advocate for genuine
progress on the environmental front than
Bjorn Lombard he's thought it through as
far as I can tell more deeply than
anyone else perhaps in the world and
it's stunning to me the degree to which
his ideals fail to gain traction and I
think partly it's because he makes the
issue complicated right he says well we
don't have just one problem too much
carbon we have like
20 problems or a hundred and
and they all need to be attended to but
we need to rank order them and we have
to do that in a methodologically
rigorous manner it's like well we don't
want to do any of that we just want to
feel good about what we feel good about
and we want to make claim that that
makes us morally virtuous and it's
certainly the case as far as I can tell
that our Educational Systems are
enticing young people to adopt exactly
that attitude and then to also engage in
this demonization that you described
so I think one one powerful Dynamic with
this this free virtue that you get by
just saying I care about this issue I
care about the planet is that it's been
given the stamp of science because it's
considered scientific to just say hey
the planet is being destroyed by fossil
fuels we need to do something about it
and it's really as long as you feel some
way or you vote some way that is
considered totally sufficient there's
nothing to think about but so it's
really sad and shameful that science has
been has been stamped on this incredibly
irresponsible way of thinking and one
thing I've tried to do and I think Bjorn
does this but I I think I do it probably
most explicitly and I think it's very
very important to do it explicitly is I
keep talking about the benefits of
fossil fuels and how how the other side
is ignoring the benefits of fossil fuel
so I go as far as to call the other side
fossil fuel benefit deniers I also call
them climate Mastery deniers because
they deny our ability to master climate
danger and I think people can really get
that we're thinking about this issue in
a way that makes no sense because is
we're only looking at the negative side
effects of fossil fuels we're not
looking at the benefits and if you look
at my work the moral case for fossil
fuels fossil future it's really
stressing the goodness of fossil fuels
not just fossil fuels aren't as bad as
you think but they're an actual positive
good and I've seen you make this case as
well I think it's very very powerful
it's imagine my book had been called
fossil fuels aren't quite as bad as you
think it would have made no impact
what's really needed we've had this
inverted morality that said that that
says that food is poison and poison is
food and I think it's not enough to just
to say oh they go too far it's say no
they are attacking something good and
once you are right positive case for
fossil fuels the other side goes on the
defensive if you watch what happens when
I debate when people will debate me they
don't really have an answer to looking
at the full picture their answer is call
me a climate change denier try to smear
me but they can't answer the argument of
if you look at the full context benefits
and side effects of what's good for
human flourishing fossil fuels are
incred incredibly good and will remain
good for the foreseeable future and it's
a pretty simple that that climate change
denier phrase is a real interesting one
too because that's a phrase that's so
manipulatively propagandistic that it's
almost incomprehensible I mean the
reason that that phrase emerged is
because there's been we've developed a
universal consensus that denying the
reality of the Holocaust was a moral
crime
and so the propagandists took a leap
from that page and said well the people
who are denying the cataclysmic reality
of climate change are as morally
culpable as those who deny the Holocaust
which implies that they're as culpable
as the Nazis who run the death camps and
that's a pretty decent smear and then
you might say well what's the moral
advantage to doing that and so the first
thing you might point out is well you
get to have all the unearned moral
virtue that goes along with saying that
just because you're sentimental about
the planet in some vague way that you're
now a moral Paragon and that solves all
your moral problems and then
conveniently at the same time you get to
identify a group of people who are
essentially satanic in their motivations
and so that would be the climate change
deniers and so that entire problem of
evil which you no longer contend with in
your own life because you're on the side
of the moral is dumped at the feet of
the people that you deem as enemies
that's that form of skate skate
scapegoating that Renee Gerard talked
about and so young people are being
enticed to do two things is one is to to
adopt it three things to adopt an
extremely simple-minded view of the
problems and opportunities that confront
us
second to claim a completely unearned
moral virtue merely on the basis of a
vague sentiment
and third and more dangerously to
localize the problem of evil in the
minds and Souls of the people who are
hypothetically opposed to their
self-aggrandizing sentiment and the
combination of those three moral errors
is really dangerously toxic and that
dangerous toxicity I would say is
manifesting itself in such things as
these this idiot insistence let's say in
the UK
because they're suffering from this more
than any other place now maybe except
Germany on the moral benefits of an
impossible net zero right the the rubber
is really starting to hit the road in
the last couple of years as Energy
prices have spiked out of Out Of Reach
of many people
and the unreliability of these
hypothetically benevolent Renewables has
become more and more self-evident
and so we're walking a very dangerous
moral path here right easy moral virtue
the the our inability to point out that
a lot of this moral virtue is driven by
an unthinking ignorance combined with
this temptation to demonize those who
well like lomberg shellenberger you
you're a good example as well who are
standing up and saying hey wait a minute
everyone
um we've lifted billions of people out
of absolute privation and starvation
as a consequence of the utilization of
fossil fuels and they're so fundamental
that we can't shift away from them
rapidly that's actually practically
impossible without tilting people into
the kind of abject poverty that's going
to cause widespread starvation it's like
that doesn't sound like a case being
made by Satan to me
no it's uh I mean I do think that the
energy crisis is an enormous Educational
Opportunity it's obviously a tragedy and
it's as somebody who's been talking
about this for 15 years and Advising in
the opposite direction it's very sad to
see be myself being right in terms of if
you artificially restrict the supply of
fossil fuels in a world that needs more
energy and you don't have a viable
near-term replacement then prices are
going to Skyrocket including food prices
and the price of everything else like
this this was obvious that this was
going to happen and it's hard to see it
but at least the benefit is that people
can see that the establishment has
failed that's the benefit of a crisis
people see the establishment has failed
and the key is in my view two things one
is the right people need to be
implicated and the right people need to
be Vindicated and I say the right people
need to be implicated not as a
vindictive person at all but it's very
important when you have a crisis and
this happened with 9 11 happened with
the financial crisis you know you need
to have some idea of who is responsible
and then who was right and gave us
better advice if you look at today's
energy crisis the number one thing that
is scary about it is that it is a crisis
that has come from the from the Net Zero
movement not even only achieving one
percent of their goals so they have not
even reduced the supply of fossil fuels
I want to stress that again they haven't
even reduced the supply they just slowed
its rate of growth they already wanted
to dramatically reduce the supply that
was their goal we were supposed to be
using way less fossil fuel by now they
just slowed the growth and that was
enough to cause a global energy crisis
in a world that needs far more energy so
that should really wake us up what if we
actually start on their path of getting
rid of fossil fuels and again we have 27
years now 27 years and less than a month
as we record this to achieve Net Zero
which in effect means getting rid of
fossil fuels we could talk about offsets
and stuff but that doesn't work at any
scale that there's any evidence of so
it's really this this homicidal movement
in its in its consequences and I do
think people are waking up up and
they're particularly waking up to the
idea that hey we ignored the benefits of
fossil fuels or what I call our
designated experts did this and these
people need to be jettisoned you cannot
listen to anybody about energy and
climate who ignores the benefits of
fossil fuels to billions of people
because if you do you get an energy
crisis and if we keep listening to them
it's going to get a lot worse
well the other thing that you see being
the drum being beaten on the side of the
radical left for example is the
anti-colonial
um
let's say this continual trumpeting of
the anti-colonial interference message
and so then I look at that and I think
well you give the devil is due and the
fact that the world's cultures have come
into contact with one another in a
dramatic way in the last 300 years has
produced all sorts of consequences some
positive and some negative
but um
on the anti-colonial front the
environmental proposition and this is
mostly coming from the radical left is
that
there's no possible way that the third
world
inhabitants can be allowed much less
encouraged to develop a standard of
living that in any manner approximates
the profligate West is that we're rich
and you know maybe we should suffer from
that a bit and maybe we should pay
reparations let's say but all those poor
people who are desperately trying to
clamber up the socioeconomic hierarchy
so they don't die let's let's make that
perfectly clear they can't be allowed to
do that because their environmental
footprint will immediately become so
large that the planet itself will be
destroyed and so okay what's the
consequence of that well the
consequences of that is that they should
be poor and stay that way and should
shut the hell up about it and should be
happy about it and perhaps there should
be a hell of a lot fewer of them and if
that doesn't trigger your
anti-colonialist morality then you've
got some serious thinking to do because
I just don't understand at all how it is
that those of us in the wealthy West and
this would certainly include those in
the chattering environmental glitterati
Elite Class I have no sense whatsoever
how they're in a moral position to be
lecturing the developing World about how
they should accept limits to growth
which means for example that their
children won't have access to enough
nutrition to even optimize their their
brain development as they mature it's
like oh that's the price those people
get to pay a those people those poor
people in developing countries who don't
get to be wealthy and and by wealthy
means have enough to eat and have
schools to send their children and we in
the Western World we can sit on our high
horse and say well we used fossil fuels
and oops sorry about that and all the
carbon but you bastards you can just
you can just accept your lot and if you
stop breeding so God damn much that
would be a good thing too now how that
is it's Colonial to a degree that's
overwhelming is beyond me
well it's it is and I think it's a very
very powerful argument it's been one of
these things that has been ignored
because the priorities of the modern
environmental movement are not what they
say and I would say more broadly the
anti-capitalist movement they claim to
be concerned about the poor but if
you're concerned about the poor and you
know that fossil fueled productivity has
brought an unprecedented number of
people out of poverty in recent decades
you would think about how do we expand
that how do we replicate what happened
in China what happened in India you know
some changes to it obviously but how do
we how do we you know they use seven
times more fossil fuels compared to four
40 years ago like it's it's obviously
fueled their productivity and their
prosperity why don't we do more of that
and yet there's been no attention paid
in the culture to the energy poor
there's no attention paid to the fact
that we have three billion people who
use less electricity than one of our
refrigerators uses we have a third of
the world using wood and animal dog to
eat their homes and to cook their food
and in terms of you're mentioning
wealthy people
three quarters of the world uses an
amount of energy that that we would
consider totally unacceptable in the U.S
or Canada or anything resembling that so
once these facts are pointed out it is
obvious that there is a moral imperative
to do at least nothing to get in the way
of people
at least that and it's clear that the
anti-fossil fuel movement is absolutely
getting in the way they're trying to
destroy all loans to fossil fuels there
they're trying to encourage them to use
things that will not actually work for
them they're trying to for example
throughout Africa limit oil and gas
development even though that's a huge
potential source of prosperity but
they're not winning this argument once
sunlight has been exposed and I had a
personal experience I don't know if you
heard about this but the Washington Post
tried to basically cancel my book fossil
future uh back before it came out they
got a copy of the book they didn't read
the book which that I thought that was
their job as journalists a report on a
book from a major author instead what
they tried to do is dig up what I had
written in college where I had said very
specifically the poor world needs more
capitalism and more individualism which
I stand by but they somehow tried to
portray that as colonialism but here's
the key their whole argument was Alex
Epstein doesn't really care about the
poor so you don't have to listen to his
arguments about the poor needing fossil
fuels this is a bizarre ad hominem on
its face it's completely the opposite of
the truth but it was notable to me how
they had no answer to this argument that
poor people need fossil fuels and that
the anti-fossil fuel movement hurts the
poor people most so I think that really
shows the power of this argument
let's delve into that issue of caring
about the poor because I don't think
that it is really all that wise for any
of us to jump up and down about how much
we care for the poor because if you
cared for the poor you'd be out there
doing something with your life to
directly benefit the poor and that turns
out to be extremely high I have to I
don't mean I don't mean you I don't mean
you oh okay and speaking more generally
it's not that easy to care about the
poor and so I think that any of us who
Trump at the idea that we truly care
about the poor should be very careful
about that but having said that I would
also say we could though say even if we
don't care about the poor any more than
the typical somewhat selfish human being
we could at least get the hell out of
their way when they're trying to clamber
their way up to socioeconomic hierarchy
and that was the case that you made just
a few minutes ago is that we could at
least in the west not Implement policies
that actually
interfere in a serious manner with the
attempts of the developing world to lift
themselves out of absolute privation we
could at least get the hell out of the
road and we wouldn't have to do that by
hand waving about how moral we are in
our care for the poor we can say well
we're relatively disinterested at
minimum but we won't go out of our way
to make your lives more miserable than
they have to be well you use your own
efforts to acquire for yourself some of
the things that we've managed to acquire
we can't even do that
I think it's a great point and so for me
yeah I don't want to act like I'm just
ministering to every poor person of the
world or this kind of thing I mean look
I I live in a free country I love doing
work that I find really interesting and
I love that it benefits a lot of people
including some of the poorest people in
the world and one the particular way in
which I identify with the poorest people
in the world is with the lack of freedom
because I really think about what what
would it like be like to not be born in
the U.S whatever advantages I had being
born in the U.S is by far the greatest
and I really think about you know how
can more people be born into that and
really the number one thing we need to
do to do is spread good ideas and not
spread bad ideas and and this is where
the anti-fossil fuel movement is so
destructive particularly you've probably
seen this recent climate reparations
thing yeah which is saying hey we owe
the poor world and I I wrote about this
recently people can see it at
energytalkingpoints.com which is where I
post my new stuff but the there's
there's the the idea yeah that we should
feel guilty for ruining the world and I
believe we've made the world better for
everyone including the poor but the
other element that is obviously wrong is
what is happening is we are paying
people off usually dictators off to not
use fossil fuels so we are paying them
to deprive people of the crucial freedom
to get prosperity and that is just
totally shameful and that is absolutely
interfering in the lives of the world's
poorest people
right so with our so-called climate
reparations that are going to be devoted
to the the governments of third world
countries primarily we're going to be
propping up frequently brutal
quasi-dictatorships and bribing them to
keep their populations poor yes so that
we don't save the planet
that's our plan
that is that is that is the plan I mean
again it's it's not a movement that
actually has any kind of goal and
strategy long term it's really just
hostility toward any impact and at the
moment it's CO2 emission so anything
that has CO2 missions you hate but
observe look there's no enthusiasm for
nuclear right which you would expect
them to love because it doesn't emit CO2
there's hatred for nuclear there's
hatred for hydro and there's hatred for
mining which is necessary for solar and
wind which require way more mind
materials than anything else there's so
it's really an anti-impact movement
that's just hostile to any human impact
and just nihilistically and randomly
pursues that with no strategy and no
thinking about the future and this
mentality is leading the world this is
what I call our knowledge system it is
blindly pursuing this destructive
anti-human path with no strategy okay so
let's let's delve into that a little bit
that motivation for that so I'm gonna
play devil's advocate here a bit and and
let you you respond to it so
the first thing we might point out is
that the the human proclivity for
something approximating unspoiled
natural Vistas actually seems to have a
moral element and a biologically rooted
moral element so for example our our
aesthetic preferences seem to be
associated
with something like preference for
natural landscapes that are verdant and
green and potentially productive in
relationship to Agriculture and and the
flourishing of let's say edible animals
with enough water we like Landscapes
that look like that we think they're
beautiful and the idea that we might
prefer those if they were
unspoiled is also worth delving into to
some degree because
we do need to live in
balanced Harmony
with such environments so that we don't
destroy the very virtue that they they
implicitly contain and so in our
aesthetic preferences tilt Us in that
direction and so we have a bit of a
biological tilt towards not wanting to
gum up and pollute the works
okay so so there's that and then we also
have this moral sense that
we have a moral obligation right and so
the moral obligation is
to be grateful
to be cognizant of our unearned
privilege and so for you that would be
the fact that you were born in the
United States and that you were a
accidental beneficiary of all the work
that had gone into that Great Society
before you made your appearance on the
scene and that there's a moral
obligation on your part in some sense to
do something about that right and so and
that can both of those can be warped the
warping of the first one is to push that
moral and aesthetic sensibility to the
point where we claim that any human
interaction with that pristine
environment whatsoever is tantamount to
to to to to immorality
and on the second front it is that
the way to atone for our privilege is by
being guilty and stopping all activity
so those things dovetail we might say
instead that if we wanted to
genuinely contend with the problem of
our unearned privilege and the fact that
you know we walk on blood that is being
we walk on land that is being soaked by
the blood of conflict for Generations
right there's a certain guilt in that a
certain sense you might say even of
original sin is that we do have to atone
but the proper proposition on the
sophisticated front would be something
like well we should atone by putting
into place thoughtful and intelligent
and genuinely pro-human environmental
slash economic policies
and we should atone in our private lives
for our unearned privilege by being
people whose moral striving is so
admirable that we've Justified the
existence of our privileges
and we shouldn't be taking the easy way
out and saying just because we're
sentimental about Gaia means that we've
somehow fulfilled our moral obligation
we're doing a very bad job of teaching
young people this as far as I can tell
so like the guilts there right the sense
of original sin is there the sense that
we're responsible for the atrocity of
history in some sense is there that
needs to be contended with what we're
constantly looking for easy ways out of
the problem instead of actually trying
to address it head on
well let's start out with the the first
part in terms of this this like sense of
what we like in natural landscapes and
we like life and so I certainly have a
version of this myself I mean I'm very
obsessed with the ocean and I spend way
more time Outdoors than most people and
I just like I think people under rate
being outdoors a lot and and you know I
love seeing different kinds of animals
and their natural habitat so like I
definitely experienced this but when I
when I think of it then what I think
about is in impacting the Earth we want
to make sure we impact the Earth in a
way that allows us to really enjoy this
and in fact have more of it there's a
lot of things we can do to make the
Earth more beautiful and to enhance it
with respect to our aesthetic
sensibilities and I think the the best
thinker ever in this regard was Frank
Lloyd Wright because if you look at his
buildings and how he approached it he
loved nature but he also thought that we
could improve nature and that's really
what you're doing as a human being is
you're saying I can improve nature so
you're not hostile to nature but you
view it as what I call Wild potential it
has the potential to be an amazing place
for us it has all these different
building blocks and all these starting
things and some of them we want to
preserve some of them we want to change
a lot and even the things we want to
preserve we want to make a lot more
accessible to everyone which requires
changing a lot so I think of it as we
can do an even better job at making the
Earth an amazing place to live but part
of that is recognizing we've done a
really good job in a lot of ways the
Earth is so much of a better place to
live than it was 500 years ago 200 years
ago the world is is is you know it's
naturally it's naturally Dynamic it's
deficient and it's dangerous it's like
those are three attributes that's why I
call it wild potential and so human
beings have had to contend with that and
to bring up fossil fuels our basic way
of contending with that is to try to
produce a lot of value that nature
doesn't produce for us nature produces
not very much value that we can use and
it produces a lot of threats so we need
productive ability to create resources
nature doesn't including to create
resources that neutralize the different
threats like creating irrigation to
neutralize drought and what we do that
with our productive ability but we're
naturally very physically weak beings
and so the key step is using machines to
produce far more value than our meager
physical bodies can and that's what
we've done with fossil fuels we've had
cost effective energy that has allowed
say the average American to have 75
machine servants producing value so that
we can do far more than we ever could
and we can do types of things that we
never could like no number of human
beings can fly no number of human beings
can be an incubator which you know save
Millions incubators save millions of
lives so we've made the Earth so much of
a better place and I think we can make
it even more beautiful and I think a lot
of the specific things we create are
ugly and that's a shame but I think of
it as we've done a good job and we can
do even better not that we're these
Sinners who have ruined who ruin
everything by touching it that is a that
is a hostile View and it's an
unjustified view so I think we can be
more like Frank Lloyd Wright but we
should be proud of what we've done so
far in terms of obligation I mean I feel
gratitude for it I don't feel like
anyone has really sinned or I've sinned
or but I feel like the obligation is to
is to keep going is to keep trying to
make it better and better and I think
just by being a productive person that's
really what you're doing but because I
think about global issues I try to
advise people globally
so let me ask you about this
psychologically so obviously people
there are a lot of people particularly
young people perhaps who are bearing a
heavy load of existential guilt for the
fact of their very existence and so you
just made something approximating a
pro-human case and so I would ask you a
psychological question
how do you think you've conducted
yourself in your own life
effectively
so that that sense of existential guilt
that potential hostility towards human
endeavor itself or even human existence
has been ameliorated like what have you
done that you believe is sufficiently
valuable to justify the cost of your own
existence
but I guess why would I I don't
understand why I would feel it in the
first place because the people who feel
it have a very warped at least the
environmental version we can talk about
other versions but the environmental
slash climate version is this very
warped delicate nurture view of the
earth that the Earth is stable
sufficient and safe and our impact ruins
it and if you believe that and you hear
all this propaganda then you think yeah
we're all we're all ruining the delicate
nurturer but if if you have that view
it's a very damaging view but I don't
have the view so I don't I don't
understand why I would feel so bad yeah
but people that's the thing is that and
I think we need to contend with this
right because people do have that view
and lots of people have it and it's easy
let's say for educators who are pushing
this ideological agenda to capitalize on
the prevalence of that view that's why
I'm pointing to something like an
intrinsic sense of original sin is that
we have this sense as human beings or
many people do that in some real sense
we have to atone for the crime of our
existence and I think there's something
to that I think that we have to bear a
moral burden that justifies the the
crime of our existence so to speak and
that would mean that we have to be
genuinely well in your terminology we
have to be genuinely productive people
let's say we have to be genuinely
productive people that are aiming up
maybe in relationship to such things as
working for the amelioration of absolute
poverty like there is a moral calling
there and I think that part I think of
it differently okay I think of it
differently so I think of existence as
an opportunity so I think of it as it's
just this amazingly special thing that
you know any of us exist in the first
place I mean probably you think about
the probabilistic nature of it and I
feel like being on Earth is just this
amazing opportunity and you can look at
how different people have handled that
throughout history and how they handle
it today and I think a lot of people
tragically haven't made the most of it
but I think you can see certain things
that people do who have made the most of
it and find it fulfilling and for me one
of the observations is people who choose
a certain kind of creative work it it is
makes a huge difference I'm guessing
you've experienced I've certainly
experienced this in terms of just
finding something that creates value in
the world that really really works with
how you like to use your mind the
thought process hopefully you get to
work with certain kinds of people I mean
that's just part of it there are all
kinds of other opportunities of being
alive so I don't think of it at all as
oh it's we're guilty and this is bad I
think the only guilt is wasting the
opportunity that's that's where my kind
of fear and guilt come in is like I
worry about oh did I waste the
opportunity of being alive and part of
that is of course you don't want to live
at the expense of others and ruin that's
another way of wasting it but so I think
of life as opportunity not as not as
atonement
well right and we should also we can
address there too the issue that if you
conduct yourself successfully so let's
say that you are as a consequence
prosperous there is also this underlying
presumption that's generally unexamined
that you had to do that at someone
else's expense right it's something like
a zero-sum game and that ties into this
whole malthusian view that we're yeast
in a Petri dish with finite resources
and the truth of the matter I think is
that
if you conduct yourself
in the highest manner properly then you
end up being creatively productive in a
manner that doesn't just benefit you
selfishly but simultaneously benefits
many other people and also facilitates
their ability to do the same thing and
so that's a vision that's a kind of
Harmony that's a high order ethical
calling is you don't have to pursue your
creative exploitation of possibility at
the cost of the possibility or at the
cost of other people quite the contrary
you could increase the possibility which
we could do on the natural front and you
could increase the ability of others to
flourish simultaneously
yes and I want to really highlight
because earlier you responded you said
all these people have been have been uh
immersed in this what I call this Dogma
this delicate nurture dogma and I would
add a piece to this dog by it's it's the
view that the Earth is delicate nurture
that's stable sufficient and safe and
then it goes along with what I call the
parasite polluter view of human beings
which you're getting at with the
malthusian view so the view that all we
do with our impact is we take from the
earth and we destroy it we make it ugly
we disrupt it and this kind of thing and
insofar as you view the world this way
you are going to have a bad life and
you're going to be really unhappy
because you're going to feel really
guilty and you're going to feel really
pessimistic and you're going to believe
in all of these apocalyptic scenarios so
it's it's why it's a fundamental thing
that needs to be done to re-educate
people about the basic nature of Earth
and the basic nature of human beings and
replace so delicate nurture with what I
call Wild potential and this parasite
polluter view with what I call the
producer improve overview we actually
produce value and we can improve the
Earth and we can do even more and in
fossil future I talk about this is part
of the human flourishing framework a key
part of how we have to think about this
issue is change our view of human beings
in Earth from an anti-human View to a
pro-human view and if once you change
that in people it is life-changing
because it's their their whole view of
how the world Works changes from this
terribly sad and destructive View to a
very optimistic View and that that's one
of the things I'm grateful for is early
on I learned pro-human environmental
philosophy and that was a huge gift that
I got when I was 18. how did you learn
that why were you fortunate enough to
learn that well maybe we'll leave that
look we we have to stop we have to stop
this part of we'll get into that in the
next part of our discussion so for
everybody who's watching and listening I
do an extra half an hour
with my guests on The Daily wire plus
platform as part of the arrangement that
I've made with them to increase the
professional appearance and quality of
my podcasts for example which as you are
noticing are still available
um on YouTube free for wide distribution
I do an extra half an hour with people I
would be interested and I'm going to
continue to talk
um to to Alex
on The Daily wire plus platform about
his philosophical Journey because you've
definitely taken an unpopular stance and
a minority unpopular stance and you did
that pretty early 2014 is pretty early
given all things considered and and you
did it quite successfully you haven't
been
particularly effectively canceled
interestingly enough and I'd like to
find out
what your pathway was to your
realizations and how you managed that
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com